when people come up to me and I do my
jokes and they laugh and they accept me
and I have fun that's what makes me
happy at my age and I don't know if it's
bad as somebody who's so sensitive
though are you not concerned that maybe
that somebody that you say something to
will feel
upset yeah yeah so um now again I have
that
you know Rickles attitude you don't like
me it's okay if Rickles would say if you
like my show fine if not fly Ozark Air
like he at the end of his show said you
know I'm not a rabbi priest a reverend
he said I'm God but he said I do jokes
to laugh at ourselves and you know I
don't mean any harm that's the kind of
Comedy I do and that's the same with me
I'm a good guy but this is the style
comedy I do it's like a wise guy insult
style comedy it's not it's a character
it's not me as a person right but but
people like that character for some
reason it catches on because no one does
it and it's just so bizarre and off the
wall but are you not afraid that that
and I'm just asking the question and
this is how I I always feel like I and
because I'm on a show like AGT and I
have to be honest sometimes with
somebody and go that wasn't great
anybody polite
I do right but I also hear that I heard
somebody's feelings and I feel
devastated that somebody's feelings got
hurt by what I said so like even at when
I was watching you at the Ethan thing
did you not even though she was
attacking you right do you are you not
concerned about how that lady might take
the fact that you were pointing out her
size yeah I I do I do because I think
about you know when Jeff Ross was in
here and he's uh do you know Jeff yeah
entitled never match up but he does
insult comedy
the roast Master General I was with him
last night I had dinner with him last
night but he says he there's part of his
show where he asked a member of the
audience to come up on stage but he will
never do it unless they volunteer
themselves and no one else volunteers
them so he's very he's intentional and
careful about they have to want it and
be in volunteering to get roasted but
you go up to people who are sitting I
think Jacqueline my beauty magic or or
Devastation whatever you want to call it
or Devastation
it's like shock comedy because if I go
up to a girl right and she's heavy and I
go I know when you get a shoe shine you
got to take the guy's word for it and
she's like what it's not expected right
it makes it funny because I walked up to
a girl saying hey I'm a comedian can I
do a couple Rose jokes and she goes sure
so I do a couple Road Strokes it won't
make an impact with the camera of the
reaction because they know ahead of time
so I try to do a surprise attack
[Music]